thema sonnenschein ab ans meer
ja das darf man wieder zumindest
teilweise in mecklenburg vorpommern
haben die strände geöffnet für
einheimische touristen müssen wohl noch
ein bisschen warten und auch die
gastronomie soll wieder öffnen für
einheimische und wir haben uns
umgeschaut an den küsten und ich möchte
jetzt schalten zu meinem kollegen markus
hibbeler er ist am norddeich markus
strömen die menschen schon an den strand
oder halten sie sich noch zurück ja die
korona lockerung zeigen auch hier
positive auswirkungen an der
niedersächsischen nordseeküste die
menschen strömen hier seit mehreren
stunden kontinuierlich an den strand bei
bestem frühlingswetter und temperaturen
um die 20 grad also viele leute nutzen
das schöne wetter entsprechend aus und
wie ist die stimmung am strand zählt man
sich da an mindestabstände oder wird es
da jetzt schon auch mal ein bisschen
ausgelassen
ja der strand ist zum glück relativ
weitläufig und entsprechend mehrere
hundert meter lang so dass das mit dem
mindestabstand überhaupt kein problem
ist der dürfte locker einzuhalten seien
trotzdem ist es hier recht gut gefüllt
und der wir wissen draußen scheint die
sonne aber ist es wirklich so waren das
die ersten sich auch schon ins wasser
trauen ja ein paar sind schon im wasser
jetzt ist gerade auch die flut gekommen
wir haben ja hier wattenmeer in der
niedersächsischen nordseeküste und man
sieht schon tatsächlich die ersten
wagemutigen die sich in die fluten
stürzen gerade sehen wir im hintergrund
sehr schöne bilder wir wären alle gerne
dabei markus vielen herzlichen dank an
den norddeich wir schalten jetzt
anfragen nach frankfurt auf die berühmte
zeit dort steht meine kollegin jessica 4
jessica ist dort schon der kaufrausch
ausgebrochene oder sind die menschen
doch lieber draußen und liegen in den
parks na ja das wetter lädt hier ist
nicht unbedingt ein so shoppen und
eigentlich auch noch nicht ganz so zum
in den parks liegen und in der sonne zu
suhlen
aber die stadt fühlt sich so langsam ich
glaube das liegt auch ein bisschen daran
dass die leute jetzt so langsam
aufwachen und gucken was denn hier so
los ist es bilden sich keine schlangen
vor den läden nur anfangs gab es hier
und da mal eine
von einem buchladen aus den klamotten
geschäft aber auch nur weil der laden
noch nicht auf hatte wie sieht es denn
in den großen läden aus die jetzt
endlich wieder öffnen dürften die über
800 quadratmeter haben sind dort denn
die menschen eingeströmt
ja also vollzahler gibst du mir eine
sehr lange schlange schon bevor der
laden auch ausgemacht hat sobald die
türen aufgingen sind die leute da rein
es waren jetzt keine massen die sich
darum irgendetwas geschlagen das ist ja
auch nicht viele sonderangebote oder so
und die halten sich aber auch alle
extremen an die masten pflicht die
schaum wirklich dass die leute an den
abständen voneinander reingehen und auch
dass sie sich im laden nicht unbedingt
bedrängen oder bedrängen
jessica vielen herzlichen dank nach
frankfurt und wir schauen jetzt nach
berlin dort steht auf dem kudamm eine
kollegin maren witte auch dort wollen
wir mal nachfragen sind die menschen in
der hauptstadt in shoppinglaune wie sie
zum kudamm aus hallo wir sind inzwischen
nicht mehr am ruder im vision zur
schönhauser allee gefahren prenzlauer
berg doch hier ist auch der ansturm
eigentlich komplett ausgeblieben ist
normale stoppen
nochmal shopping leben der berliner es
bilden sich keine schlangen
ansonsten ist auch ganz ruhig denken
viele werden schon die parks begeben
weil es doch schön warm es heute mehr
als 20 grad werden
wir machen das kann man verstehen dass
es da die menschen eher in die parks als
in die läden lockt vielen herzlichen
dank an die schönhauser allee in
prenzlauer berg